I'll go Andrew my name is Pierre back
welcome back to some more Sicilian siiiy
hallo sauce [ __ ] off penguins [ __ ] off
look at my slalom like ass [ __ ]
I haven't seen that Mr penguins okay
they must react uh we need to go ahead
left here we hadn't need to go upstairs
[ __ ] off penguins no one likes here what
happened penguins thunderstruck playing
all right here we go
yes let's go upstairs we need to go to
the music room and your list isn't
chemistry I think check the map music
room we got our pretty good close to the
chemistry i penciled it si si si molto
Buono
I don't know where there should be a
door here oh no animes there such poor
excuse of penguins seriously so it
should be here to delay [ __ ] the
atmosphere in this game I got a I think
oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] what I want right here purple
are you Bieber thing give me that can we
call I'll [ __ ] take that [ __ ] [ __ ]
the same bands man what about food
oh no they're here [ __ ] off I'm gonna
name you Larry Larry I don't like you
I'm going in here that's what you get
Larry that's what you get for not
opening door there's a hand here
let's look at it hello hand statue of an
old man's hand the fist shut tight as it
would never let go
these are the things that I think makes
Silent Hill so [ __ ] creepy these kind
of stuff I don't know this is really
something that you what should I do it
should I use the chemical right
chemistry [ __ ]
Piplup hey tomorrow
that's how I get all the MLS all right
sayonara a gold medallion oh [ __ ] yeah
I'll take it
you better believe your sweet ass I'm
gonna take it now let's say how to Larry
I think that what is his name like [ __ ]
up Larry how many twins to you huh
[ __ ] out all right don't touch it
don't you dare touch me liar all right
we need to go I guess here yeah when you
don't know got it we use a ground war of
them serious ah how's my health I should
probably drink a little bit drugs don't
do them kids they make you feel better
but not in a long time not that I would
know anything love it how what the [ __ ]
what is have you penguin friend I'm a
clicking everything it never works
come on [ __ ] off Larry my god you can't
have my nipples get into your twin Larry
I didn't see your [ __ ] twin [ __ ] your
and your twins Larry [ __ ] up all right
oh [ __ ] I need to turn here why don't
you dare [ __ ] attack me [ __ ] ah I'm
more of that what the [ __ ]
oh it's the [ __ ] kiddie room shut up
kitty I'm not going fall for that again
uh how's our health we can't die now I'm
gonna kill myself if we die that doesn't
make sense
take that [ __ ] up your [ __ ] alright
alright shut up kitty I'm not gonna save
you uh kitty you're desperate okay sure
alright alright alright alright how the
hell
snore [ __ ] oh oh my [ __ ]
it's up in my ass what do we do
I need Larry don't you dare touch me
[ __ ] you Larry oh [ __ ] I think I passed
it give me the map oh [ __ ] yes yes SF
justice in here in here oh thank god
alright music room it's a piano how you
doing oh we need to put the medallion
before I forgot [ __ ] my [ __ ] alright
what is this written in blood a title of
birds without a voice first flew the
greedy Pelican
here you go for the reward white wings
falling so that's a white key then came
a silent dub flying beyond the Pelican
as far as he could okay so as far as
Raven that's a black key it's higher
than the dub just to show that he can
all right and then the Swan glides in to
find a peaceful spot to another bird
finally out comes the crow that's
another black coming quickly to stop
then napping who will show the way who
will be the key who will lead to the
silver reward the silver medallion
goddamnit
alright we need to head out of here and
I gotta tell ya I [ __ ] kill you I
can't even see you and AH there's no
Larry's who'd have thought
it's gonna be Larry's over here though
where's the clock tower oh that's right
it's over here let's put the medallion
and get the [ __ ] out of here
yes let's put the medallion bro put the
medallion bro Larry's coming yes
[ __ ] penetrate that shed all right
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right yay hi
they creep me the [ __ ] out all right
left left baby no I don't know I don't
think we can walk left where did we come
from again I never know let's go here
yes
all right and upstairs I hate how you
can't waste ammo in this game all right
right and then left right no I'm gonna
run into them [ __ ] it out don't touch me
seriously you look at the map now oh
[ __ ] I'll just [ __ ] where it's my life
doing I'm just taking it anyway I don't
give a [ __ ] it's not worth dying right
now we came so far to lose it all what
if we turn off the radio let's turn off
the radio
off I heard that they can't see you but
this is a lot of crepe Pierre ah [ __ ]
alright um the music room
so come on it is way too scary
uh dad apostle Holly then I can have
this here okay uh all right I think I
got it uh nope
here we go there we go and then Raven
and then peaceful spot and then Raven
eyes that one okay and then you and then
you and then you uh yeah all right all
day all night good if I'd like to part
on this night I I just wanna eat your
dies all right let's pick you up buddy
come here buddy you are beautiful let me
shoot you silver medallion that's
because I saw that piano puzzle like a
bass okay let's go outside but first we
will look at this picture
beautiful let's go more no more Larry
this is all I'm asking for all right
what do we got
come on bring it I shed the ambience the
[ __ ] Amiens chat tell me this is not
the creepiest [ __ ] thing oh [ __ ] they
can't see me that's even they can't say
hey [ __ ] up oh I can't use the map
either Shay ah ha ha
okay let me just check the map really
quick now here they can see me though
why the [ __ ] am I supposed to go I need
to go there [ __ ] dude please be the
right one this is the wrong one isn't it
I don't [ __ ] know yes it's wrong on
your nidian pity god dad myself for
being so time we turn that off we turn
that on
alright inject oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god I put it in put it in put
it in I don't know what we're gonna do
in this tower Scouts for boobies or
something no not a ballet ballet go
outside that's the [ __ ] where'd you go
in what's the problem oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this with this with this [ __ ]
everywhere [ __ ]
since the eyes fly okay pity just be
quiet then they can't say oh [ __ ] you I
hate them I hate them with a passion how
am I supposed to go I think I know I
stayed downstairs here hopefully yep
uh-huh
it's so dark and so like no way pets we
got this okay hello hello creepy room hi
then let me push this ah nice house ah
precious [ __ ]
yes now we can go inside okay we just
got a run past the Larry's someone just
came get free turning this off now I
don't give a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] me so
hard
seriously do it I don't care if you rape
me okay uh whatever all right your caddy
wash my I just whatever was lobby okay
let me think
you go left go left pity just go left go
right look all that fit in you got it
you got this [ __ ] don't tell me this is
died it's [ __ ] dog your daddy at
parity okay great you Jesus
we came so far we came so [ __ ] far
what am i health what am i helps keep my
health my health my my have I I don't
know anyone I'm so screwed
shut up Amyas shut the [ __ ] up Oh
Oh where do we go in down ah it's the
skips getting better and better does it
I really don't want to play this anymore
I hope the [ __ ] is this you're kidding
me
I really don't want to play anymore I
really just want to save this game and
get the what what the [ __ ] is going on
what why are we here am I
what have I been here before yeah we
were your second ago bro Harry what the
[ __ ] is going on here what the [ __ ] is
going on here serious I don't remember
this being I don't remember either her
and you don't seem nuts amazed by it
well at least Larry is not here oh come
on
[ __ ] this Amiens [ __ ] this game okay I'm
gonna bring it [ __ ] oh hey
[ __ ] me oh hey Oh Larry you are so
gentle with me what is going on in here
oh come on Larry please please why why
do you insist BAM
that's for Oprah [ __ ] don't
think I can't see you're still not oh
[ __ ] off sit up
okay I'm screwed I'm literally [ __ ]
right in the back I don't have skills
enough for a game like what I saw how
that's nice I love what you did with the
place Larry I thank God a health pack
just give me that [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] put it up my [ __ ] if I
have to Larry you're not supposed to be
here this one is for uh breast for
nipples okay
they [ __ ] respawn out please tell me
this is open ah come on
dude what's going on in here
a bar I love balls gimme that
give me the ball a rubber ball
[ __ ] you out say the [ __ ] out of that
why did we get a rubber ball why are
they dolls on the walls ah
I want to stop playing but I can that
it's [ __ ] aah aah I didn't want save
and I have to do it all this again and
I'm not doing all this again I'm just
not throwing it
what are you when what are you how are
you dead are you dead or not
it's a [ __ ] doggy sir is it I'm gonna
end the episode here and I'll just make
another one I [ __ ] [ __ ]
he just follows me everywhere I don't
even know what I did I didn't know the
barrel was his mother I mean [ __ ] her
dog [ __ ] me
oh that ass is so nice